judges across the country ordering ice
to release hundreds of illegal immigrant
detainees despite the fact that many of
the facilities in question
have zero cases of CO fit 19 in a new
foxnews.com op ed our next guest says
judges are using kovat 19 as an excuse
to free detained illegals Tom Holman his
retired ice director and author of the
book defend the border and save lives he
joins us now Tom thanks for being here
and great op-ed I had that had the
opportunity to read it so you're saying
these judges are never missing a moment
they're pointing to these facilities and
saying you got to let them out because
they're not social distancing even
though the facilities don't have covin
19 problems yeah it even goes beyond
that Pete that the judges are paying
attention what's going on he doesn't
know what's going on these detention
facilities our detention facilities had
the highest detention standards in the
industry and our private contractors our
facilities have twice as many medical
professionals any other state local
facilities they're doing testing every
day if someone's become symptomatic
they're doing the Cova tests on them and
they're keeping a cohort or well while
they go through the tests I mean they're
doing more for the illegal aliens in
detention than most American citizens
are getting in public these judges
aren't making a ruling because the
health and safety of illegal aliens
because they did there's zero cases they
just wanted my Saudis they just want my
own they just want them out which is the
goal to begin with now these folks are
in because they broke the law in the
first place by being here illegally but
also we're talking about other crimes as
well oh absolutely if you look right now
we release over 100 criminals because of
the decision of these judges in New York
City is the release of a subject who is
a rape of a child
you've had three murders but been
released you have a person in
Massachusetts that was released I was
convicted of rape then we have
congressmen like Jay Paul AOC Castro
Omar they're all calling for more bodies
the Congressional Hispanic Caucus wants
to illegal aliens at least across the
country
I mean this is a congressman that turned
the back they turned her back on the
very laws they enacted and they want to
continue to vilify the men and women
will enforce those laws this is the the
the Pro illegality open borders
crowd laid naked before us it's
precisely what they want they don't want
any these facilities at all as we've
heard will this happen are they gonna be
released or will could these orders be
blocked
well DLJ is fighting and they need it
they need to fight the Brenda fight for
our lives right now so the department
just needs to appeal these decisions and
taking the highest courts and look if I
was the ice director if I was I strike
two right now what I would do I do a
press release every single day and tell
the American people who's being released
whether criminal convictions are and
what judge by name ordered that release
hold them accountable they should own
those decisions and when they reoffended
when another child is raped or some
other US citizens rape were murdered
then call it out this person was
released because of this judge on this
date and they reoffended on this day we
need to educate the American people
what's going on here makes my blood boil
especially when you consider we talk
about testing across the country and
it's grade a level testing in these
facilities yet it's not good enough for
folks who break our laws and commit
crimes real quick zero Cobra death zero
called vid definitely detention which
means it has nothing to do with kovat as
you pointed out tom great great op-ed at
foxnews.com appreciate your time and
great book by the way
all right thanks you got